le président zellenski ne veut peut-être
pas à nommer les localités mais la
bataille la plus intense ce qui semble
s'être soldé par une victoire a eu lieu
autour de ballaclia qui est une ville au
nord-ouest de isum dans la dans le sud
de la région de harkis je ne sais pas si
vous avez une carte sur l'écran ou si
vous l'avez en tête mais ce que les
forces ukrainiennes sont en train de
essayer de faire c'est de pousser vers
le nord-est et donc de couper is Youm
qui est dans le sud de la région de
harkis juste avant le dans le bass tenu
par les Russes et de pousser vers la
ville de coupian's qui est plus dans le
nord-est de cette région de harkif c'est
une contre-offensive surprise en quelque
sorte les Ukrainiens avaient annoncé
leur contre-offensive dans le sud dans
la région de Herson mais il n'avait pas
beaucoup parlé de la région de harkif
alors est-ce que ils ont vu une
opportunité puisque les Russes avaient
redéployé beaucoup de force pour
défendre la région des Herson dans le
sud ou est-ce que c'était cela toujours
le plan le sujet fait débat mais en tout
cas ce sont des succès que les
Ukrainiens ont remporté qui sont
confirmés par les experts Ukrainiens
excusez-moi les experts américains à
l'Institut des études de la guerre à
Washington qui disent même que l'Ukraine
aurait repris quelques 400 km
dans la région de harkif Gulliver
Bonjour Quels sont les informations dont
vous disposez en ce qui concerne les
autres fronts notamment celui de Herson
alors d'abord dans la région d'aersonne
la contre-offensive continue mais il
semble clair que les batailles sont très
incendes intenses et qu'il y a des
pertes importantes des deux côtés les
Ukrainiens ne veulent pas annoncer la
prise de localité il semblerait qu'il
reprenne du terrain mais tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que c'est très
difficile et que c'est une
contre-offensive qui va prendre
plusieurs semaines et puis ici où je me
trouve dans le Dan basse il n'y a pas de
contre-offensive
on peut appeler à une contre-offensive
dans le don de base mais ceux qui se
passe selon les soldats à qui j'ai pu
parler hier c'est que les Russes ont
plus ou moins arrêté d'avancer c'est
vrai qu'ils ont pris récemment le
village de pisky jusqu'au nord de la
ville de Donetsk mais sinon leur
tentative de prendre des villes comme
parkmout par exemple semble être à
l'arrêt les soldats hier m'ont dit que
si il y a quelques semaines ils avaient
par colonne de tank très nombreuses
maintenant s'ils essaient de faire est
percé sur des terrains c'est vraiment
par des très petites unités qui sont
assez faciles pour les Ukrainiens à
repousser mais ces soldats m'ont tout de
même dit que l'artillerie continue à les
bombarder et que dans la région de
Donetsk en tout cas les forces
ukrainiennes ne sont vraiment pas en
position de pouvoir monter une
contrefossive en ce moment tout ce qu'il
peut faire c'est défendre mais il
défendent bien il ne perde pas vraiment
de terrain